>> Dagen: THE WHITE HOUSE
DOING SOME SERIOUS DAMAGE
CONTROL AFTER THE
SECRETARY DEFENDANT
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S PLAN TO PUSH
BACK -- BY GOING DOOR-TO-DOOR.
>> TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS SPENT TO
TRY TO KEEP AMERICANS ALIVE
DURING THIS PANDEMIC SO IT IS
ABSOLUTELY THE GOVERNMENT'S
BUSINESS, IT IS TAXPAYERS'
BUSINESS IF WE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO SPEND MONEY TO KEEP PEOPLE
FROM CONTRACTING COVID AND
HELPING REOPEN THE ECONOMY.
>> Dagen: NOW TRYING TO WALK
BACK THAT COMMENT, CLAIMING HE
WAS TAKEN WILDLY OUT OF CONTEXT.
THAT IS A WAY TO CONVINCE PEOPLE
TO GET VACCINATED, THE
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO SHOW UP
AT YOUR DOOR.
>> Jesse: I HAVE AN IDEA, I
DON'T HAVE GOOD IDEAS OFTEN BUT
THIS IS A VERY INNOVATIVE IDEA,
TELL ME IF THIS WORKS, IF YOU'RE
WORRIED ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
VACCINATED, WHY DON'T YOU CREATE
AN APP, PUSH A BUTTON AND YOU
HAVE A DOCTOR COME TO YOUR HOUSE
AND JAB AT YOU.
THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF BUILDING
WEBSITES, JOE BIDEN KNOWS HOW TO
BUILD A WEBSITE, REMEMBER?
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THIS,
WHY DID THEY HAVE TO HAVE TO GO
DOOR-TO-DOOR?
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO
DOOR-TO-DOOR.
IF SOMEONE COMES TO MY PROPERTY,
NOT ALWAYS A GOOD RESULT AND I
AM A LIGHTWEIGHT, THINK ABOUT
THE PEOPLE IN TEXAS, I WOULD NOT
WANT TO HAVE THAT DUTY TO PUT ON
A COAT AND WITH A SYRINGE GO
KNOCKING ON PEOPLES DOORS AND
THAT IS A RECIPE FOR DISASTER.
BUT IT DOESN'T EVEN KNOW THE HHS
SECRETARY'S NAME, HE FORGOT IT
AT THE PODIUM TODAY AND I THINK
AGAIN THIS IS THE GOVERNMENT
TRYING TO GO WHERE IT DOESN'T
BELONG AND YOU DON'T EVEN NEED
TO GET 100% VACCINATION, YOU
JUST NEED TO KILL THE VIRUS AND
RIGHT NOW, OF THE VIRUS IS
ALMOST DEAD.
MORE PEOPLE GETTING SHOT OVER
THE WEEKEND ON JULY 4TH VAN ARE
DYING OF COVID.
>> Greg: TO YOUR POINT PEOPLE
ARE GOING DOOR-TO-DOOR AND
SHOOTING PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: SERIOUSLY.
REMEMBER BIDEN USED TO HAVE THE
CARD WITH THE BODY COUNT OF
COVID-19?
HE NEEDS A NEW CARD, STREET
VIOLENCE.
MAYBE HE COULD REFERENCE THAT
NEXT TIME.
>> Dagen: PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NATURAL IMMUNITY FROM COVID, IF
YOU PRECLUDE THOSE, MORE THAN
8 OUT OF 10 AMERICANS HAVE
IMMUNITY.
ABOUT 85%.
WHY THE PANIC?
>> Dana: ONE THING I WOULD SAY
TO JAVIER BECERRA IS YOU ARE NOT
IN CALIFORNIA ANYMORE.
IT'S A DIFFERENT SITUATION NOW
AND YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE YOUR
WORDS CAREFULLY.
WHO IN THE WORLD WOULD LOOK AT
ALL THE COVERAGE ABOUT VACCINE
HESITANCY AND VACCINE PASSPORTS
AND CONCLUDE THAT THE BEST THING
WE CAN DO TODAY'S ANNOUNCE WE
WILL GO DOOR-TO-DOOR WITH THE
VACCINE?
BUT THEY ALSO DIDN'T CLARIFY.
THEY SAY CONSERVATIVES ARE
BLOWING THIS UP AND EXAGGERATING
IT BUT YET AT THE SAME TIME THE
MEDIA CAN'T EXPLAIN WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION REALLY MEANS BY
THAT.
IS IT GOING DOOR-TO-DOOR WITH
INFORMATION LIKE A LEAFLET?
MAYBE THAT'S FINE BUT IS IT
GOING DOOR-TO-DOOR WITH -- I
DON'T THINK IT IS GOING
DOOR-TO-DOOR WITH -- THEY WERE
NOT SPECIFIC AND YOU HAVE TO
CHOOSE YOUR WORDS WITH CAUTION
AND SENSITIVITY IF YOU ARE GOING
TO DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE AND GET
PEOPLE VACCINATED OR GET THEM
THE INFORMATION THEY CAN NEED SO
THEY CAN MAKE THEIR OWN DECISION
BECAUSE IT ISN'T POLITICAL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE VARIOUS
GROUPS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
HESITANT ABOUT GETTING
VACCINATED, AND THIS IS A
WHITE HOUSE THAT HAS NO SOFT
SELL, NONE, AND THAT IS WHAT IT
TAKES.
>> Jessica: I AGREE WITH DANA,
WHEN I TALKED ABOUT THIS FOR THE
FIRST TIME I WAS LOOKING IT UP
FIERCELY TO BE LIKE, OKAY, ARE
WE GETTING MORE INFORMATION?
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS A GOOD
THING WHEN PEOPLE GO GRASSROOTS
CAMPAIGNING, VOTE FOR SO-AND-SO,
I DIDN'T THINK THEY WERE GOING
TO SHOW UP TO JAB PEOPLE BUT I
WANTED TO KNOW IF THEY WOULD BE
TRACKING NAMES BECAUSE WE DO
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNMENT
ATTRACTS BROAD NUMBERS ABOUT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HIV/AIDS, LET'S
SAY, BUT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFIC NAMES OF THAT.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE IS A RICH
HISTORY OF TERRORIZING PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY GOING BACK TO THE
'80s, SOME MORE INFORMATION,
MORE SPECIFICITY ON THAT BUT IT
IS A LITTLE BIT OF A POLITICAL
PROBLEM, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
STATES, 18 OR 19 STATES REACH OF
THESE 75% GOAL, THEY WERE ALL
BLUE STATES.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE THE DELTA
VARIANT IS HAVING ITS PAYDAY IT
IS IN RED STATES AND 99.5% OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE PASSING AWAY FROM
COVID-19 RIGHT NOW ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNVACCINATED.
WE HAVE MORE WORK TO DO.
I CAN'T SAY IT IS NO BIG DEAL.
STREET VIOLENCE IS A BIG DEAL
BUT COVID IS STILL A THING.
>> Greg: THIS IS THE PROBLEM,
IS THAT WITH THE NEW VARIANT,
THIS COULD NEVER END.
TECHNICALLY, IT COULD GO ON
FOREVER.
VIRUSES, EVERY YEAR NOW WE ARE
PRIMED TO SEE ANY OUTBREAK AS
COVID 2, COVID 3, THE RECKONING.
IN THE GOVERNMENT IN THE MEDIA
WILL EXPLOIT IT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES.
IF THEY SEE ANY INROAD FOR POWER
OR CONTROL THEY'RE GOING TO USE
IT, SO THIS IS -- HAS AMAZING
POTENTIAL FOR CONTROLLING THE
POPULATION AND THAT IS WHAT
WORRIES ME.
WE HAVE TWO PARTIES.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALWAYS FOR THE
SOLUTION OF BIG GOVERNMENT
INTRUDING INTO YOUR LIFE AND
REPUBLICANS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL, ABOUT, WE
ARE RUGGED INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, STAY OFF MY PORCH.
WE CAN ACTUALLY WORK TOGETHER
WITH THIS BUT I HONESTLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS.
IF YOU ARE JUST SHOWING UP WITH
THE LEAFLETS YOU ARE WASTING
PEOPLE'S TIMES BUT IF YOU
ACTUALLY SAID, WE ARE GOING TO
BE DRIVING AROUND YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD, WE HAVE A VACCINE
VAN, I HAD ONE OF THOSE, THAT IS
FINE, BUT I THINK MY CONCERN IS
THAT THIS THING COULD KEEP
GOING, KEEP CREATING POTENTIAL
PROBLEMS THAT NEVER REALLY
MATERIALIZE AND THAT WILL KEEP
US SCARED AND ENTHR